hi i'm priyanka regardia and in this
episode of deconstructing chatbots we
will continue to help
the pugs team extend their single flow
agent into a multi-flow agent
that can handle not just orders but also
returns
we will also see how they can manage
multiple agent versions
and deploy to different environments
[Music]
before we dive into the console let's
lay out the use case requirements first
most of pug's customer requests are of
three types
orders returns and exchanges each of
these requests have their own
conversational twists and turns
and three different teams that manage
those we recommend pugs to create
three separate flows for these requests
multiple flows allows different teams to
be responsible for building
and maintaining those flows and they
provide better conversational control
help scale quickly and they don't incur
any additional cost
we already created the order flow in the
previous episode
if you haven't watched it it is linked
below stop and watch that one before
continuing here
because this is going to be the
extension of that episode
we will be creating a return flow so
pugs can take
return requests through the virtual
agent we will keep the flow
simple by just collecting the order
number and providing a return
confirmation
okay so now that we know what we're
building let's head to the dialogflow cx
console
let's continue working in our pugs
project add
two flows to it for return and exchange
in our return flow at the start page we
define
our transition route to order dot return
intent
which will understand the user's intent
add a few examples of training phrases
such as
i need refund i would like to return my
order
add a few more along the same lines and
before
saving this let's add the transition to
a page
to collect return information in this
page
let's ask the user for the order number
i've provided a few examples here
to process a return we need the order
number so we will make that as a
required parameter
and for now let's just select a system
entity number
although in real life pugs would
probably have a custom entity with a
certain sequence of numbers that would
be matched
to their backend through the web hook at
this state
we check if the order number is received
by adding the condition
page.params.status equals final
once the condition is met we want to
transition to
another page to provide a return
confirmation
at the return confirmation page all we
do is send a confirmation
saying your return is processed adding
our session parameter or a number
in there using the dollar sign and we
transition from here to the end page
although we could transition to another
flow as well if you wanted the user to
say
take a survey or order more things
there's a lot more that you can do in
returns you could add more parameters to
collect
connect to the pugs back-end api but i
will leave that to you to explore since
the point of this video is to get you
familiar with the cx console and the
concepts
now we know that pugs has multiple teams
working on the flows
they need the ability to save progress
by creating different versions
and then deploy specific versions of
their flows to development
testing or production environments let
me show you how versions and
environments work in pugs
agent we go to the manage tab and in
deployment we find
versions now here since pugs has
multiple flows
each flow can have its own version so
the teams can independently manage their
own versions
versions are immutable snapshots of the
flow data
and associated agent data like intents
entities
web hooks pages route groups and a lot
more
now if we click on a flow here let's say
return
create a version give it a name and
description
and give it a few seconds to become
ready and if we want to use this version
then we can just load it in our draft
slow by clicking on this button
but let's make another version so we can
actually see these changes
say in this new version we made a change
to our entry dialog
then go to the versions and load our
previous version
we see that the change we made is not
there anymore
because we are now working in an older
version
so that's how versioning works in cx
now as a best practice pulse obviously
wants to separate their production
and development environments to make
sure the development can keep going
while production is stable to do that
we go to environments and create a new
environment
let's say production in this case and we
select the corresponding flow versions
that should be used in production we can
do the same to set up dev
and test environments too now once
environments are
set up make sure you're testing things
in the right
environment in the simulator you can
select the environment and the
corresponding flow
if you're using the api pass the
environment id
in the url like this otherwise it uses
the default environment
which is your draft flow all right with
that
we have created a multi-flow agent for
pugs team that takes orders
and returns we also learned how versions
and environments work
in dialogflow cx now it's your turn
design the third exchange flow for pugs
team
and share your experience with me in the
comments below
[Music]